levanten la mano por favor quien alguna
vez haya dicho no me gusta ir a la
escuela
macará four
alguna vez se han preguntado eso
alguna vez en preguntado porque no me
gusta ir a la escuela
cuando nosotros vamos a cualquier
negocio que ofrezca servicios como
entretenimiento restaurante consultoría
etcétera gastamos nuestro dinero
esperando satisfacer una necesidad
pasarla bien y divertirnos o simplemente
resolver algún problema deseamos recibir
el servicio adecuado a nuestras
necesidades
si no lo recibimos nos vamos a otro
lugar en donde si lo recibamos
porque la escuela diferente
porque la escuela no sentimos que
satisfacemos nuestra necesidad de
aprendizaje
es un servicio después de todo no
algo debe estar mal entonces pero nadie
lo cuestiona porque
porque son las escuelas las que nos
adoctrinan a todos nosotros para no
cuestionar su autoridad
repito la escuela es un servicio y no
nos estamos dando cuenta de ello lo
suficiente como para exigir un servicio
que satisfaga nuestras necesidades
pero entonces de donde surge el
adoctrinamiento hacia nosotros para no
cuestionar la autoridad de un sistema
educativo obsoleto
la respuesta sencilla del monopolio
estatal sobre la educación
damas y caballeros de que explicarles
por qué permitir que el estado eduque la
población es uno de los peores errores
que hemos cometido como civilización
humana y que ese error a pesar de los
años para citando nuestras mentes
nuestra individualidad y nuestra
libertad aún tiene solución
el sistema educativo gubernamental está
en crisis y el estado no encontrará
nunca una solución a la problemática
pues es su control sobre la educación la
raíz del problema
se gastan muchos recursos en exámenes
para determinar el nivel de los
profesores muchos reprueban siguen dando
clases y otros mucho más medio que eso
asisten puntualmente para cobrar su
quincena y hacer huelgas
verdaderas mafias se han apoderado del
sistema educativo manejan las escuelas y
la calidad de la educación empeora
los resultados son estudiantes
reprobados profesionistas incompetentes
universidades conflictivas y una fábrica
de desempleados y nadie hace nada para
atacar la raíz del problema el estado
sin años del control del gobierno sobre
la vocación en méxico y la gente aún no
se ha dado cuenta que el estado es el
peor ente que pudimos encontrar para
educar a la población educación y estado
deben estar completamente separadas
mientras escuelas no gocen de autonomía
política académica financiera y
administrativa es imposible que el país
pueda salir de esta oscura etapa de
transición social y educar a personas
preparadas para competir en un mundo
cada vez más interdependiente
la educación de méxico está por debajo
del promedio mundial de las pruebas pisa
y sólo el 1 por ciento un 1 por ciento
de los estudiantes mexicanos tienen los
conocimientos suficientes como para
posicionarse con un buen resultado en el
programa
sabían ustedes que de cada 100 niños que
ingresan a la educación básica menos de
3 terminan con título universitario y
sólo el 30 por ciento de los titulados
ejercen lo que estudiaron
y el foro económico mundial sitúa méxico
en la posición 102 de los países con
mejor calidad de educación a nivel
mundial 102
a veces parece triste el desperdicio de
potencial tiempo esfuerzo y dinero mal
empleado
porque me si y mientras sigamos
desperdiciando el potencial de las
personas educándolas y formando ellas de
acuerdo a un plan estatal no vamos a ir
a ningún lado por eso debemos señalar
señalar los males para que esto quede
más que claro y cambiar de fondo la
problemática que corresponde al
monopolio estatal sobre la educación
el cáncer nace del estado y es que
pensamos mal cuando decimos que si el
estado se hacía cargo de educar a la
población nuestro país prosperaría como
nunca
pésima idea pues se formó un modelo
educativo caro ineficaz y corrupto un
modelo educativo prusiano en donde todo
está bajo control del estado propio de
países comunistas en donde se educaba y
formaba la población bajo el mismo
programa de planes de estudio para
pensar uniformemente todos de la misma
manera
hay que darnos cuenta de algo
la minoría más vulnerable de cualquier
sociedad no son las mujeres los niños
los negros los homosexuales judíos
musulmanes etcétera no la minoría más
vulnerable de cualquier sociedad es el
individuo y lo que debemos darnos cuenta
es que los individuos no somos ni nunca
seremos iguales todos tenemos gustos
habilidades preferencias intereses
diferentes al resto de los individuos
entonces a quién se le ocurrió que una
educación planificada y colectiva es
viable y factible
una educación estatizada tiene como
resultado profesionistas que son
totalmente dóciles al estado que no
cuestionan las decisiones de los
políticos y que buscan su colaboración
con el poder
una educación en donde el estado
determina los planes y programas de
estudio para los alumnos tiene como
resultado personas mediocres que no
saben sumar lo que no saben hablar que
difícilmente escriben un reporte que
solo se disponen a recibir a recibir
órdenes a ser burócratas empleados y
subordinados
el resultado general
son parte de un sistema educativo que
despeje el talento de cientos de
millones de personas el resultado
general una sociedad con baja autoestima
y situación de víctima incapaz de
empoderarse a sí misma para tomar
riesgos y salir adelante por sí misma
cuyas personas creen que merecen todo
todo sin hacer nada por ello
a usted se preguntarán y las soluciones
tenemos escapatoria de este oscuro
agujero de ignorancia que el gobierno
crea para su propio beneficio
la respuesta es sí y la solución se
llama libre mercado y con ello me
refiero a que la solución para
deshacernos del estado en la educación
es privatizar la educación pública y
dejársela a la iniciativa privada bajo
libre competencia
de esta forma dejará de ser un monopolio
y empezará a ser considerada un servicio
los maestros que trabajan en cada
escuela pública pueden ser quienes
compras escuelas pueden asociarse entre
ellos y comprar cada escuela pública con
sus liquidaciones como trabajadores del
estado de esta forma para proteger su
patrimonio ellos deberán invertir
correctamente en su funcionamiento como
servicio
se convertirían en empresarios al
servicio de la educación
y posiblemente usted ahora me digan
héctor pero así pero tenemos la vocación
la gente con menos recursos no tendrá
acceso a ella
y yo te diré que eso es una falacia
económica y que deberías saber que en la
economía y en los negocios donde hay
demanda de algo habrá un emprendedor que
ponga la oferta de calidad y buen precio
para atender ese mercado por ejemplo
para las personas que no pueden pagarse
una matrícula en la escuela privada más
prestigiosa del país está lanza un
modelo educativo más económico para
atender ese mercado
ahora imaginemos lo siguiente
ya no existe en la educación pública
ya no habrá un gasto del gobierno para
destinarlo a ese sector
ya no debería haber un cobro de
impuestos para destinarlo a ese gasto
entonces la gente tendrá más dinero en
su bolsillo para destinarlo a la
educación que más le convenga de acuerdo
a sus propios intereses a esto yo le
llamo libertad
ahora con ello las escuelas deberán
competentes y para ofrecer un servicio
de educación de calidad y buen precio
para atraer alumnado y sobrevivir en el
mercado las escuelas más ineficientes
desaparecerán al dejar de ser
subsidiadas por el gobierno no es otra
cosa que aplicar la lógica de los
mercados libres al campo de la educación
el esquema de subsidios es lo peor que
puede le pasado del sistema educativo
pues cualquier institución subsidiada se
convierte en una empresa de cero riesgos
la doctrina de la población a pensar que
las cosas son gratis ahora del
capitalismo al mercado y a la
competencia
por eso los subsidios traen como
consecuencia la pérdida de iniciativa y
la dependencia del gobierno los maestros
dejan de preocuparse por trabajar pues
tiene ingreso asegurado y los alumnos
piensan que estudian gratis y que
deberían estar agradecidos con el
gobierno por eso mismo es esencial
eliminar el sistema de subsidios de las
escuelas
y ahora posiblemente usted me digan
héctor estás loco la educación es un
derecho que debería ser gratis los
subsidios son esenciales
y yo te diré que sí sí estoy loco y te
diré que me deje de incurrir a falacias
económicas no existe tal cosa como un
almuerzo gratis cada vez que tú das un
derecho a través del gobierno alguien
más lo tiene que pagar vía impuestos
pero es cierto algo aquí es
completamente posible eliminar el
sistema de subsidios de las escuelas y
mantener la gratuidad de la educación al
mismo tiempo que separamos educación de
un plan estatal como
con el sistema de wauters de milton
friedman nobel de economía quien propuso
que en vez de subsidiar a las escuelas
la oferta se subsidie a la demanda los
alumnos
el sistema de bowser de milton fridman
funciona de la siguiente manera el
alumno recibe un voucher que puede ser
utilizado únicamente en una institución
de educación
la escuela lo recibe lo valida y cambias
de voucher por dinero en un banco así
sin necesidad del gobierno la escuela
puede decidir qué hacer con dicho dinero
las escuelas que ofrezcan mejor servicio
de educación recibirán más vouchers y
con ello más dinero para operar
este sistema de wauters es el mismo que
se utiliza en países como finlandia
suecia singapur corea del sur entre
otros así la educación se mantiene
gratuita y separada del estado
cómo hacer que nos guste y a la escuela
al principio de mi plática menciona que
los individuos no somos iguales todos
tenemos gustos y habilidades diferentes
al resto pero los individuos
cómo potencializar esas habilidades
individuales mediante la educación
como fomentar la creatividad en las
escuelas
la educación del futuro deberá además de
ser además de ser vista como el servicio
deberá tomar de guía la teoría de las
inteligencias múltiples de howard
gardner según howard gardner las
personas tenemos diferentes tipos de
inteligencias así que la educación
tendrá detalle a potencializar las
inteligencias que ya tenemos o que nos
gustaría desarrollar de esta forma no se
perderá el tiempo en enseñarle a alguien
física cuando se tiene un impresionante
talento para las artes
y como a todos nos gusta aprender lo que
nos interesa
al darnos la escuela un servicio
satisfactorio no se empezará a gustar y
a la escuela
también las plataformas que ofrezcan
educación por internet y el internet
mismo tendrán un papel importante en el
futuro de la educación los elementos que
he mencionado a lo largo de mi plática
servirán para incrementar el respeto de
la calidad que se tiene hacia la
educación
es decir concluyendo mi plática diciendo
que la única solución contra el
estatismo es la libertad
la libertad de aprender lo que quieres y
de hacer de tu vida como quieres y una
educación separada del estado es un gran
inicio para darnos esa libertad
hay que ver la historia para darnos
cuenta que aquellas sociedades que son
más libres en donde el gobierno
interviene en menos son las sociedades
que han alcanzado la prosperidad
como dijo el gran economista de la
escuela austriaca premio nobel de
economía friedrich hayek la única forma
de cambiar el curso de la sociedad será
cambiando las ideas
mientras que frei bastiat comentó que el
estado no debería educar sino que
debería permitir educar pues todos los
monopolios son detestables pero el peor
de todos es el monopolio de la educación
comencemos con la idea de que la
abolición de la educación pública es
esencial para el desarrollo económico y
social de cualquier sociedad
nelson mandela por su lado dijo algo muy
cierto
la educación es el arma más poderosa que
podemos usar para cambiar el mundo
y vaya que es un arma muy poderosa
no dejemos esa arma en las manos
equivocadas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]